the famous roundtable on jesh lesyk says
even now he's overcome with reverent awe
when he touches it the master carpenter
made it 25 years ago today it's become
the symbol of a democratic Poland it's a
beautiful piece of furniture that I made
and it's played such an important role
in history at this table the Solidarity
trade unions Olli Dhanush and the
Communists reached an agreement you
could say the table caused a democratic
breakthrough I'm happy that I could play
a role in it the table became a symbol
for conflict resolution solidarity
leader lek valensa negotiated it talks
that threatened to collapse several
times then a miracle the Communists and
solidarity agreed to hold parliamentary
elections on June 4th 1989 the ruling
communists were guaranteed a certain
number of seats the rest were to be
occupied by freely elected opposition
members the first relatively free vote
since world war ii was a disastrous
defeat for the communists today i'm josh
lesyk heads a furniture company he's
remained loyal to woodworking saying
wood is something solid that one can
build on it's a good fit fresh lacing
the last 25 years have been good and
he's made the best of the opportunities
that came his way
yes of course I'm proud of myself let's
put it this way I've developed in the
right direction
I've become a boss
I have my employees and I'm responsible
for them I think that you can call that
a big success but he's also experienced
the toughness of the new economic system
the factory where the table was made was
sold and then closed down there is a
shopping center now where his old
workshop used to be unto his wife yet
viga is a farmer even if her work looks
the way it used to the farm is a modern
one
she says she's grateful for the
democratic development without that
change Poland would not be an EU member
and there would be no subsidies have you
filled out all your applications of
course it's done and even filed already
everything's ok
the farm is flourishing they continue to
acquire new equipment that wouldn't have
been possible in communist times NJ also
heads the Municipal Council with his
wife's help they make a good team
success not for their neighbor Yugi
Koval once a welder he quickly lost his
job when his plant closed immediately
after communism fell he collects pallets
and old boards to burn as fuel
he says you never know how bad times can
become when Angie visits him he knows
what the topic of conversation will be
he says Koval is single-minded and isn't
adapting to the new system democracy
democracy and capitalism that's fine for
rich people but this system isn't for
people like me it's not for poor people
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer his small farm barely supports
itself
he hasn't even tried to apply for EU
subsidies because he has no confidence
in the system let's say they're touched
by the fates of those who haven't fared
well the euphoria about freedom of
speech and open elections has waned we
were all fascinated at first but now the
emotions have subsided if you look at
the government and what it does and the
changes they're implementing you feel
powerless to do anything polls once
formed the courageous vanguard of
Democratic Change in Eastern Europe they
had high expectations back then and
overwhelming euphoria and although
hardly anyone in Poland wants the old
system back the round table where it all
began has come to represent Democratic
awakening but also disillusionment